it is a victory for fans and in fact the
country has been
uh united in condemning these
proposals and the government has stood
firmly behind
the footballing authorities and saying
we will do whatever it takes
to stop this proposal we were willing to
take very very
bold measures to stop this proposal
going ahead and i'm very glad that
the fans with the backing of government
and
others have had their say but it's very
important that we don't see this as the
end of the process what this has
highlighted more than ever
is the need to look at the wider
governance of football that's why i
announced on monday a fan live review
led by
tracy krauts something i think commands
support from from many people from
all different clubs and and across the
political spectrum
to look at how we address football
governance football finance and indeed
the whole fan experience
do you think though that that is uh
gonna be enough for itself to stop
these sort of moves from happening again
well
we have been clear as a government and i
was explicitly clear from sunday night
prime minister and i met with fans and
with football
uh governing bodies yesterday morning
i met with the president of uefa on
monday and i'll be
speaking to him again later today we've
been absolutely resolute
in saying that we will not have our
national game
taken away from us for profit this is
as much part of our national heritage as
our great stately homes our galleries
our museums our our theaters our
cathedrals
and we as a government will do whatever
it takes to step up to protect it and
i'm very glad that working
with fans we have given strength to fans
in
in stopping this and i pay tribute to
all of the fans and we saw it last night
with with chelsea fans they won't put up
with this and i'm i'm glad that clubs
have listened to it
i mean it's it's nice to see you
applauding the the passion and there is
an awful lot of passion
there but what about the passion of some
of your colleagues and i'm thinking of
of johnny mercer you know someone who
did three tours of afghanistan
hugely passionate about the work he did
passionate about the armed forces
passionate
about the veterans who in effect said he
was forced to resign as veterans
administered last night because
you know the prime minister is not
sticking to the veterans pledge
that he signed in the run-up to the
general election in 2019
something's got to change hasn't it well
i have a great deal of respect for
for johnny i i like him enormously and i
i work closely with him
as a minister i don't think johnny is
entirely correct on this first of all
we set up the office of veterans affairs
indeed i worked with him
on that we funded that office and we've
introduced a number of
measures to support veterans through it
in respect of veterans
uh being hounded in those real concerns
that we have pledged to
address in terms of ensuring that
veterans don't face
uh the constant threat of going back
through the courts for
the past actions forgive me forgive me
for interrupting but i know you
appreciate the type for time because
you want to move on to do something else
and but in terms of of the the constant
hounding i mean what he's saying is
you've brought in that cover for some
people but not for those people who
served in northern ireland who have
already been the subject of a lot of
investigations
we're talking veterans down in their 70s
and 80s who
mr mercer says in some cases drinking
themselves to death because they're
so concerned about what's happening to
them well
as you rightly say in respect of
overseas operations we've got
the bill that will conclude its passage
for the house i believe in the next
couple of days
in relation to northern ireland veterans
we are
currently working through government on
that we're actually
ministers as we speak are signing off uh
legislation on that which we will bring
forward in the next session
to address precisely that problem i know
from conversations with the prime
minister
that he is absolutely determined to
address this